so help me understand the uh the the
makeup it seems to me like kind of
counter-intuitive that that uh like do
you wear makeup regularly so well I did
a I did a series on um a YouTuber who I
was really fascinated by who I'm friends
with but at the time I wasn't really
friends with them uh Jeffree Star who's
like you might he's been around forever
in Myspace days so he had this big
makeup business I didn't understand at
all and I did a kind of a series with
him on my channel we were talking about
it and then he was like well why don't
you do a collaboration with me with
makeup I'm like well I don't know
anything about it but I'm one of those
people I don't know if it's OCD or what
it is but when I have a new thing that I
like want to do or whatever I get
obsessed with it so I jumped in I bought
a bunch of [__] makeup I learned how
to do it I got obsessed with it and you
say learned how to do it like uh like
how to put it on yeah like I watched
every [__] makeup tutorial video in
history I just watched all of them and
then um it was I mean but also like I
don't go out in the world and wear
makeup so yeah why do you want to do a
makeup like YouTube If like you weren't
wearing makeup or doing makeup before
that like what what made you want to do
the makeup well I want to do the series
because it was like a world I didn't
understand it was you know my friend
who's making hundreds of millions of
dollars doing this makeup stuff and I
had never seen any of it so to be able
to be a part of that and be in that was
I mean crazy but also I'm crazy I just
get so obsessed with things
um to a point where it's probably
unhealthy so I just got obsessed with it
it makes sense to me and Jeopardy star
like is known for wearing makeup while I
didn't wear makeup all the time
um wasn't there some like crazy when you
say like how many cancellations go
wasn't there something around the makeup
with the Jeffree Star the that was like
a big issue I don't remember I feel like
that you're asking me or is everybody at
yeah what was that I remember I remember
that wasn't there something about like a
warehouse being robbed or something was
that it oh yeah I mean that's the thing
with Jeffrey which is why he's such a
amazing person to film like it's always
something and that at that time that
year 2019
I would say is like the best year ever
but also was the worst year ever because
every day it was like
shit's going down yeah that day it was
Oh no I got canceled for something and
then that same day
I was supposed to propose to my then
boyfriend and then Jeffrey called me and
he's like my warehouse has been robbed
and he had all these videos and pictures
of these [__] guys scaling the walls
and like dropping in through the ceiling
and yeah just robbing all this makeup
which at the time I didn't understand
now I get it but that makeup was worth
so much money because it wasn't released
yet so it was kind of like getting
leaked to other makeup companies so they
could rip it off I don't know it's kind
of confusing yeah and he Jeffrey lives
in Wyoming right yeah he yeah he's in
all of his businesses are in Wyoming too
I think so I know he moved a lot of
stuff out there yeah it's crazy how much
money there is in makeup
it's a lot of money but it's also like
it's scary it's like it's like yeah just
things I've just the actual I mean it's
I guess it's like Hollywood not that
I've been I mean you've been at
Hollywood you get it it's like
it's just so Cutthroat and crazy and
everything changes so fast and if you're
not trending anymore if you're not this
anymore and then the up and the down and
the enemies and it's like a like the mob
like it was in one sense the makeup
world or like uh the Youtube world
I think the YouTube world I mean the
YouTube world's like dramatic I guess I
mean but it's it's more low stakes like
with the makeup world it's yeah it's
people that
there was just always something going on
with these big companies because like
yeah they're making so much money
it was yeah it was a lot I'm happy that
I'm I mean I love Jeffrey so much I'm
happy I'm less around
all the
business stuff yeah
e-commerce is the way and that way
ladies and gentlemen is called ship
station now to enjoy a 60-day free trial
you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo again that is 60 days two months
of hassle-free stress-free shipping with
ship station
yeah dude